Peter is in North Dakota
hi Peter and are you I am wonderful how
are you gentlemen great how can we help
say it my wife and I are new to FPU
we're working the baby steps on step two
and I think we've done everything the
opposite of how you teach it that's how
we learn to teach yeah so we're working
on cleaning up that mess and gonna start
with some whole life insurance policies
that we have
we each have a half-a-million-dollar
whole life policy together we pay about
a thousand bucks a month for premiums
so we're eighteen thousand dollars into
that about eighteen months in order for
us to break even with our cash value
we'd have to go with ten plus more years
nah just what then
do we hightail it and run and walk away
from the $18,000 mistake and learn from
it or did you go to a break-even at what
are your thoughts yeah the mistake is a
hole in your pocket you don't keep
putting money in there yeah there's a
whole new pocket you don't you
discovered the hole and so we you know
we don't keep putting money in the
pocket that's got a hole in it hmm yeah
it's just yeah sorry about the money
that's gone that that's um you know I
paid a lot of stupid tax in my life
stupid stuff I've done including I
actually bought a whole life policy in
my 20s and then I had learned the hard
way how to do math and it just destroyed
me when I realized what I had done
so are you guys healthy yes yep good
okay yeah we the way our I say financial
person the insurance agent who sold it
to us
it was take out big termites convert it
to whole lights and that's how you
retire so which again like I said now
now that we're learning the right way to
do it yeah Peter how did you how did you
get connected with with Dave ah my
brother said check out Dave Ramsey we
did the 14-day free trial okay
and then we binge washed and
holy crap foods we've got a big hole to
dig out of and we got to start doing it
the right way yeah so are you still in
your 14 day trial no okay pop that and
use all the tools and I guess a it oh
you did buy and you stayed in after the
14 days yeah okay we'll jump back in
there and watch the insurance lesson
again because I don't want you doing
things because I said I want you doing
things because you understand but when
you go through that whole life at lesson
in there again you're the insurance
lesson you're going to see how the whole
life works and and what you're
discovering is is the first two to three
years 100% of your money that's supposed
to be going into an investment goes in
their pocket because you've got zero
cash value right now right yeah we've
got about yeah meanwhile you pay to
almost 10x for the amount of insurance
you've got that you should have been
paying and that's why that's why this is
such a bad deal so make sure you have
term life insurance in place before you
drop this mm-hmm
okay and so it may take you a month or
two to do this but you know go ahead and
get it get it in place get in touch with
Xander insurance they can help you do
that Xander insurance com get some
inexpensive term in place the proper
amount and then go ahead and put in the
order and drop this you don't want to
drop it and then have a car accident or
something god forbid in the meantime
before the term is issued so you want
the overlap that's right Dave a thousand
bucks a month that's not unusual for
5,000 good grief yeah I mean you know
and it's so you know we eat we want
insurance to be insurance that's why we
talk about term you want your
investments to be investments and you
want your savings your emergency fund to
be an emergency fund and this whole life
stuff it has a personality disorder it's
trying to do too much and so just a lot
of it is multiple person a really truly
is and so Peter I'm so grateful that
your brother told you about the free
trial of Financial Peace University
because you wouldn't have known
you could have gone another five to ten
years so great job